oui c'est une passoire sanitaire oui
c'est une impasse sanitaire de la
réalité c'est que derrière ça c'est quoi
c'est que vous êtes contre le vaccin
[Musique]
nous fermons les boîtes de nuit quelle
étrange décision quand on sait que les
boîtes de nuit sont les premières à
avoir mis en place le fameux pass
sanitaire que vous défendez que vous
continuez à défendre et qu'on les ferme
alors que le pass and iter est encore en
vigueur faudrait-il comprendre monsieur
le premier ministre que le pass
sanitaire ne nous protège pas quand vous
dites que vous êtes content le pass
sanitaire et que vous êtes pour la
gratuité des tests pour tout le monde la
réalité c'est que derrière ça c'est quoi
c'est que vous êtes contre le vaccin
c'est ça la réalité mais bien sûr que si
oui c'est une passoire sanitaire oui
c'est une impasse sanitaire d'ailleurs
la cnil vous a demandé à quatre reprises
quatre reprises de preuves de
l'efficacité du pass je vous parle pas
du vaccin du pass sanitaires est-ce que
c'est là votre réponse finalement la
cnil non nous n'avons pas de preuve la
réalité c'est que le pass sanitaire vous
dit que ça ne sert à rien le pass
sanitaire c'est ce qui nous a permis
d'avoir une couverture matinale parmi
les plus élevés en europe
preuve en est la majorité de nos voisins
nous ont suivis ils nous ont imités ils
ont repris le pas salutaire
[Musique]